In January 2021, the Tolkien fan-site TheOneRing.net
leaked the synopsis for Amazon's upcoming
Lord of the Rings series.
Soon after, Amazon confirmed it was real.
But what does it tell us about the show and
its setting?
Here's what we learned from the Lord of the
Rings synopsis leak.
It's been pretty obvious for a while now that
the new series will be set during Middle-Earth's
Second Age.
In March 2019, Amazon Studios released a series
of increasingly detailed maps on the show's
Twitter page, culminating with a final image
that clearly showed Middle-earth during the
Second Age of Tolkien's writings.
The accompanying tweet read:
"Welcome to the Second Age."
This got most Tolkien fans pretty excited,
and with good reason, too.
Despite being filled with great stories, the
Second Age is a largely under-explored area
of Tolkien's legendarium.
Because that era spans some 3,500 years, however,
it was still pretty tough to nail down just
when exactly during the Second Age the show
is going to be set.
Now, however, things are a little clearer.
Along with reconfirming the Second Age setting,
the synopsis also mentions that the show will
begin, quote, "in a time of relative peace."
This is important, as the latter half of the
Second Age, in particular, is anything but
peaceful.
Chances are, this means that the show is due
to begin sometime between the fall of the
original Dark Lord Morgoth and the re-emergence
of his chief lieutenant, Sauron.
One thing the leaked synopsis mentions is
that the show will "take viewers back to an
era in which great powers were forged."
Sound familiar?
Yes, there's a good chance Amazon is here
referring to the forging of the One Ring — as
well as the other Rings of Power, which are
crucial to the tale of the Second Age.
All of the major Rings of Power were forged
roughly halfway through the Second Age.
This includes three for the Elves, seven for
the Dwarves, nine for the great Lords of Men,
and one for the Dark Lord himself.
"One Ring to bring them all, and in the darkness
bind them."
The Rings are originally forged and owned
solely by the Elves, who create them under
the guidance of a disguised Sauron.
Later, when war breaks out between the Elves
and Sauron, the Dark Lord gathers all but
three of them up and redistributes them to
Middle-Earth's more easily-conquered races.
While it's almost certain that the Rings are
the "great powers" mentioned here, it should
also be pointed out that the Amazon synopsis
could be talking about something else: specifically,
Middle-Earth's great alliances.
The Third Age is largely defined by the Free
Peoples of Middle-earth fighting Sauron in
isolated pockets, but the Second Age actually
features several major unions — particularly
between the races of Elves, Men, and Dwarves.
The age even ends with the famous "Last Alliance,"
which takes the battle to Mordor and defeats
Sauron during the Siege of Barad-dûr.
One phrase from the synopsis that jumps out
is the suggestion that, during the Second
Age, "kingdoms rose to glory."
While there are many strange new places that
the Amazon show will doubtless spend time
exploring, several of these rising kingdoms
will be quite familiar — or familiar in
name, at least.
During this period, Galadriel visits her future
kingdom in Lorien for the first time, while
Legolas' grandfather, Oropher, establishes
a refugee Elven Kingdom in the heart of the
Greenwood.
The Dwarven kingdom of Khazad-dûm is already
ancient when the Second Age begins, and it
plays a vital role in the politics of western
Middle-Earth.
Gondor is founded toward the end of the Second
Age too, and Elrond establishes Rivendell
around halfway through, in direct defiance
of an all-powerful Sauron.
And as for the Dark Lord himself?
In need of a home after his return to Middle-Earth,
he carves out a corner of the map for himself
— in the dark and terrible land known as
Mordor.
Amazon's synopsis mentions that the Second
Age is a time in which "unlikely heroes were
tested."
This is a vague yet tantalizing glimpse into
the show's cast of characters, which, for
now, remains largely shrouded in mystery.
Sure, a few hints have come out here and there.
For instance, Ian McKellen has said he's up
for reprising his role as Gandalf, even though
the character doesn't arrive in Middle-Earth
until the Third Age.
On the flip side, Elrond actor Hugo Weaving
has made it abundantly clear he has no plans
to come back to Tolkien's world.
And although many of the show's cast members
have already been announced, for the most
part, we don't yet know for sure who's playing
who, or if the characters they're playing
have any relation to heroes and villains we've
already seen on screen before.
The most solid actor-to-character connection
that has leaked so far is that Welsh actress
Morfydd Clark will be playing a younger Galadriel.
Other casting leaks have only added to the
confusion by throwing around brand new character
names with no obvious relation to established
Tolkien texts.
According to an October 2019 report by Deadline,
English actor Joseph Mawle will be playing
a character named Oren, who was intriguingly
described as being the lead villain of the
series.
Other new characters reportedly include the
heroic Beldor, and a female lead named Tyra,
played by Markella Kavenagh.
It was initially supposed by fans that these
were fake names disguising well-known characters.
However, the synopsis states that "the series
follows an ensemble cast of characters, both
familiar and new..."
So these could well be the actual names of
brand new characters that have been made up
for the show.
Unfortunately, the new synopsis doesn't offer
up any kind of definitive answer regarding
which heroes will be taking on the Dark Lord.
It does, however, suggest that the show will
be bringing in some genuinely fresh faces
with no obvious roots in Lord of the Rings
lore — whether the fans like it or not.
In The Lord of the Rings, Gandalf implies
that Sauron's potential return wouldn't be
the first time Middle-Earth has been dominated
by the Dark Lord.
"Sauron needs only this Ring to cover all
the lands in a second darkness."
So if that's the second darkness that he's
talking about, when exactly was the first?
Why, in the Second Age, of course.
The Amazon synopsis mentions that, at this
time,
"...hope hung by the finest of threads, and
the greatest villain that ever flowed from
Tolkien's pen threatened to cover all the
world in darkness."
These words suggest that the Amazon series
will portray Sauron's initial rise to power,
including his greatest victories and near-total
conquest of all of Middle-Earth.
Of course, this doesn't just give Amazon the
opportunity to put the show's heroes through
the ringer.
It also allows the studio to divest him of
the one-dimensional persona that defines him
throughout The Lord of the Rings.
Instead, the show is likely to introduce fans
to a much more interesting version of Tolkien's
iconic villain.
Sauron's key role in the synopsis suggests
what fans have believed for a long time — that
the show will depict the Dark Lord in his
fairer form.
While the Sauron of The Lord of the Rings
is a hideous, monstrous figure — or a giant
eye, if you're watching the movies — he
was once able to make himself appear, well,
pretty darn sexy.
More specifically, Sauron spends much of the
Second Age masquerading as Annatar, the Lord
of Gifts.
This charismatic disguise allows the Dark
Lord to mingle with the Elves and, for a while,
gain their trust.
Sauron remains in his fair form for much of
this time, and only loses the ability to look
like this when Númenor is destroyed towards
the end of the Second Age.
Obviously, Sauron's prettier persona doesn't
make him trustworthy by any means — as the
Elves soon discover for themselves.
Nonetheless, the chance to portray the Dark
Lord in this way will likely add another fascinating
layer to a villain not often associated with
nuance or depth.
There's no question that Sauron is the biggest
threat to Middle-Earth during the Second and
Third Ages — but that doesn't mean he's
the only monster hiding in the shadows.
Notably, the final sentence of the leaked
synopsis begins with the line "From the darkest
depths of the Misty Mountains..."
This line has some fascinating implications
for the direction the show might take.
It suggests that viewers will be taken deeper
than the thriving halls of Khazad-dûm, to
explore the terrible, unexplored spaces beneath
the dwarven kingdom.
So what's actually down there?
Well, for one, there's the Balrog known as
Durin's Bane.
"You know what they awoke in the darkness
of Khazad-dûm.
Shadow and flame."
This fiery demon isn't just a terror to all
and sundry; it's also fiercely independent,
having found itself without a master after
the destruction of Morgoth.
As such, although Durin's Bane is supposed
to be asleep for much of the Second Age, it
could still turn out to be an important part
of the Amazon series.
But the Balrog isn't the only thing living
beneath the Misty Mountains.
When Gandalf discusses his battle under Moria
in The Two Towers, he mentions that:
"Far, far below the deepest delvings of the
Dwarves, the world is gnawed by nameless things.
Even Sauron knows them not.
They are older than he."
Considering Sauron and the Balrogs fought
together in the First Age, it's clear that
Gandalf is referring to something altogether
more horrifying than Durin's Bane.
And while Tolkien never elaborated on what
creatures lurk in those darkest depths, it
seems that the show may just tackle that question
for itself.
One of the more specific lines in the synopsis
is the brief mention that the story will span
"to the majestic forests of the elf-capital
of Lindon."
This naturally leads to the question: what
and where is Lindon?
The short answer is that Lindon is an important
Elven nation that exists throughout the Second
Age.
More than that, though, Lindon is a very complex
and important place that plays a vital role
in many of Middle-Earth's stories.
It sits in the western reaches of the continent,
right next to the area that eventually becomes
the Shire.
It's also the place where the Grey Havens
are located, which is where Frodo and Bilbo
sail from, into the West, at the end of Return
of the King.
In the Second Age, Lindon is one of the most
powerful kingdoms in Middle-Earth.
As Sauron's darkness spreads across the world,
it becomes a beacon of hope to the Free Peoples
who stand against the Dark Lord.
Ruled by the Elven King Gil-galad, Lindon
also plays a key role in forging crucial alliances
with Men and other Elves, and ultimately provides
much of the muscle needed to topple Sauron
at the end of the age.
The last sentence of the synopsis states that
the show will also take viewers "to the breathtaking
island kingdom of Númenor."
The involvement of this island nation of Men
was a forgone conclusion from the first moment
the Second Age was confirmed.
Nevertheless, knowing that Númenor will get
its fair share of the spotlight is exciting
news for fans of Tolkien's legendarium.
The godlike beings known as the Valar gift
the island to its inhabitants early in the
Second Age, and the Men of Númenor continue
to flourish there for centuries.
The Men of Númenor eventually get tangled
up with events on the mainland and, for a
while, become the focus of Sauron's obsession.
Unfortunately, the Dark Lord's machinations
ultimately lead to the total destruction of
the island and the near-extinction of its
people.
One of the final lines in the synopsis reveals
that the show's characters will go "to the
furthest reaches of the map."
This is a particularly interesting statement,
as it can basically mean one of two things.
On one hand, this could be a veiled reference
to the Blessed Realm of Aman, the land that
lies hidden in the West.
This is where the Valar and the Elves live
in blissful harmony, and it's also where Middle-Earth's
Elves sail after their time on the continent
comes to an end.
Otherwise known as the Undying Lands, this
continent and its blessed dwellings are focal
points of the First Age of Middle-Earth.
However, Valinor also plays a role in the
events of the Second Age; most notably with
regards to the eventual downfall of Númenor.
On the other hand, the synopsis could be referring
to the eastern regions of Middle-earth.
These are areas of the map that were hardly
ever explored, even by Tolkien himself.
However, Sauron's influence is particularly
strong in these lands, and the Dark Lord recruits
many of his soldiers from their inhabitants.
If the Amazon show does head in this direction,
it's likely that Tolkien fans will get to
experience a side of Middle-Earth they've
never seen before.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.